It's hard to get to space.
As much as we all wish there were an easy
and affordable way to see how pennant
of floating in the dark.
Right now,
the only way is to become an
astronaut or a billionaire,
but there is a concept that might make
it possible while serving as the starting
point for the exploration of the universe,
the space elevator.
How exactly does it work
to understand how a space
elevator will get us into space?
We must first understand wasn't always
as being in [inaudible] basically means
falling towards something,
but moving fast enough to mess.
If you throw a ball on earth,
it makes an arc through the APP
and then hits the ground in space.
Gravity makes you move much the same way,
but if you move sideways fast enough,
the curvature of the earth makes the
ground fall away beneath you as fast as
gravity pulls you towards it.
So to enter Earth's or bears,
rockets have to go up and sideways fast.
By contrast,
a space elevator taps into energy from
the earth's rotation to get the cargo
going fast.
Imagine a child spinning a tie on a
rope with an ant on the chance hand.
As the aunt climbs out along the rope,
it starts to move faster and faster
as it ascends compared to rockets.
With cargo launched on an elevator,
you only need to provide
the energy to go up fast.
Solid ways movement comes free
with the Earth's rotation,
but a space elevator would without a
doubt be the single largest and most
expensive structure ever built by humans.
So is it worth it?
It all comes down to costs.
Rockets been a huge amount of rocket
fuel just to get a small amount of cargo
into space.
At current prices,
it costs about $20,000 to about
one kilogram of payload into space.
That's one point $3 million for the
average human, $40 million for your car,
billions for an
international space station,
this immense cost is one of the major
limitations of human space flight.
Even with advancing technology,
there's cost isn't likely to be comparable
with the price of an airline ticket
anytime soon,
a space elevator would solve
this problem after construction.
A space that of Acer is protected to
reduce the cost 100 fold to $200 per
kilogram effort. Inexpensive
space elevator costs, $20 billion.
Then we'll recoup our losses after
launching only 1 million tons close to the
weight of two ends
national space stations.
So what would a space elevator
look like in real life?
A space elevator has
four major components.
The Tata anchor counterweight and climate.
The elevator part of the space in a
visa is the [inaudible] and the climate.
It extends from the surface
of the earth to space.
The climate is like a
conventional elevator carriage.
A chamber that works its way up and down.
The tether at the base would be an
anchor pinning the tethered to the earth
along with a port for climbers.
At the top is the counterweight
which holds up the tether.
The tether is held tight like a rope
and supported from above by the tension
from the counterweight located higher
than 36,000 kilometers above the earth's
surface. At the counterweight
could be a space station,
a launching point for all missions
from the spaceport innovator.
But can we actually build one?
It's hard to say.
The biggest challenge is the tether.
It needs to be light, affordable,
and more stable than any
material we can produce.
Right now there are promising materials
like graphene and Diamond Nana threads,
but even they may not be strong enough
and aside from being incredibly strong,
the tether would also have to
withstand atmospheric corrosion,
radiation and micrometeorites
and debris impacts. Additionally,
it takes several days to climb the
elevator. How do we power the climber?
It requires a lot of energy to go up.
Do we need a nuclear reactor on our
elevator carriage or do we beam at power
from the ground with a super powered laser
and where do we get the raw materials
for a 36,000 kilometer long tether?
Do we make it on earth and launch it
into space or do we make it in space and
lower it down to the earth? Could astroid
mining with the answer put simply.
There are still some major technological
hurdles to overcome and a space
elevator is not without risk.
Should the had a break,
it would collapse in spectacular
style. If it breaks me, the anchor,
the force exerted by the counterweights
will cause the entire elevator to rise
up ascending into space.
Should it break near the counterweight,
the tether will fall.
Wrapping around the world and whipping
the end of the resulting debris in always
could pose serious problems
to future space light.
If we build a space elevator on earth,
we have to do it right the first time.
For these reasons,
some experts have proposed first
building a space elevator on the moon.
The moon's gravity is much
weaker than the earth,
so a flimsier but exist in material
like Kevlar could serve as a tether.
Even with all these challenges,
the payoff of having a working
space elevator would be a maths.
It might be the first step to truly
becoming a space fairing civilization.
Maybe we will never build a space
innovator, but in trying to do so,
we might learn an awful lot and when it
comes to the exploration of the universe,
there can't be too many dreams.
Have a glorious future.
This video was sponsored by
squarespace.com/nutshell with Squarespace.
You can make your own website,
blog or store without knowing a
thing about web design or coding.
It's basically a piece of technology
that removes stress from your life.
So if you want to support courts cause
and to and make yourself a website,
go check out Squarespace and use the code
nutshell to save 10% a few words about
sponsorships and courts cause out.
Patrion is a huge help and means we are
producing more videos but we want to
make even more so in order to ensure that
the whole team can spend all that time
working on new videos for you.
We've partnered with some companies
who we think are doing great things.
This will enable us to complete some
ideas we've been wanting to work on for a
while now like the immune system app and
book videos about history and just more
stuff for you in general.
You get more content and you get to learn
about great products and services and
we get to spend our time making things
for you to enjoy. Everyone wins.
Graduations,
if you've watched this far,
here are more videos if you
need to procrastinate more.